أريد أن أعود إلى الوحشية في
هذا الهجوم الذي ارتكبته حماس لأنه
أرعب العالم ومع ذلك
قال مكتبكم في اليوم التالي هذا الاقتباس، لقد
حققت المقاومة حتى الآن
انتصارات رائعة خلال هذه العملية
وهذه نقطة مضيئة في التاريخ.  فيما يتعلق
بنضال الشعب الفلسطيني ضد
الصهيونية، لقد وصفت بنفسك
الهجوم بأنه نصر تاريخي، فكيف
يمكنك أن تصف ذبح
المدنيين الأبرياء بأنه
نقطة مضيئة، دعني أطرح عليك
سؤالاً: هل احتلت إسرائيل فلسطين
أم العكس من ذلك، الفلسطينيون الذين
يحتلون إسرائيل؟  الأول هو
الاحتلال رداً على
الاحتلال 75 عاماً من الذل
يمكننا العودة ونتحدث عن 75 عاماً
ولكني أتحدث إليكم تحديداً
عن هذا الهجوم الذي عجل بالحرب
التي
أسألكم على
وجه التحديد لماذا
السائدة والموسعة  الهجمات على
غزة أدت إلى مقتل 7000 امرأة وطفل
لماذا لا ترى
كلا الجانبين الجانب المحتل نعم تعلم
أه نحن لا نوافق على
قتل المدنيين أريد أن
أتحدث عن وقتك في نيويورك لأنك
تحدثت في  أنا والأمم المتحدة أريد أن أقتبس
ما قلته لمشاهدينا قلته
أقول بصراحة لرجال الدولة الأمريكيين أننا
لا نرحب بتوسيع الحرب في
المنطقة ولكني أحذر إذا استمرت الإبادة الجماعية في
غزة فلن يسلموا
من هذه النار  أن التهديد هو أن إيران
مستعدة حقًا لخوض حرب ضد
الولايات المتحدة [موسيقى]، لا نريد أن تنتشر هذه الحرب
ولكن مع كل الاحترام الواجب،
لا يبدو أن أفعالك تتطابق مع كلماتك التي
تقولها إنك تلعب لعبة
دورًا بناءًا في المساعدة على السلام والأمن،
لكن وفقًا
لمجموعات البنتاغون التابعة لإيران، فقد
استهدفت القوات أو القواعد الأمريكية في
المنطقة 15 مرة على الأقل حتى الآن منذ
17 أكتوبر، حيث
أسقطت مجموعة حاملة الطائرات الأمريكية 15 طائرة بدون طيار أربعة.
صواريخ كروز التي أطلقتها إيران تدعم
المسلحين الحوثيين في اليمن والتي كانت موجهة
نحو إسرائيل، قال الرئيس بايدن هذا
أمس إنه
قال إن أي هجوم يتم تنفيذه في
المنطقة وإذا كانت المصالح الأمريكية
مستهدفة من قبل أي
مجموعة تعرف أنها مرتبطة بجمهورية
إيران دون  أه تقديم أي
دليل هو أمر
خاطئ تماما كما ترى قبل أسبوعين كنت في
العراق أيضا في سوريا ولبنان وكنت
أرى عن قرب وشخصيا أن
شعوب
المنطقة حساسة للغاية تجاه
التطورات في فلسطين
كانوا
غاضبين لأنهم لم يتلقوا أوامر
منا فهم يتصرفون وفقًا
لمصلحتهم الخاصة أيضًا ما حدث ما
نفذته حماس كان
فلسطينيًا بالكامل وقرروا تحمل
المسؤولية عن ذلك